when the cable channel history decided
to branch out into scripted programming
it didn't take any half measures the
network's first foray vikings is a
historic drama on a truly epic scale
here are five things you may have missed
from the very first episode of vikings
but be warned we'll be talking about the
episode's impact on future episodes and
seasons
spoilers for vikings ahead for the most
part
vikings tells its story without breaking
out of the narrative mode to provide
lots of road historical exposition
instead viewers have to look for context
clues to place a series events within
the loose historical record
as the first episode begins we get a
subtitle eastern baltic
793 a.d for those of us going in without
much knowledge of medieval history this
is just a helpful way to establish the
setting of the show for those coming
into this series with some knowledge
about the history of the actual vikings
that date has a very specific
significance the year 793 is considered
by most historians to mark the beginning
of what we now know as the viking gage
to be more specific historians consider
the norse raid on a monastery on the
island of lindisfarne off the coast of
northumberland in the northeast of
england to mark the beginning of this
tumultuous era
we see a dramatized depiction of that
famous raid on the show's second episode
after ragnar goes rogue to build his own
seafaring ship
and travels west despite earl harold's
son's insistence that they continue to
raid the lands to the east
i don't care what you believe
insulted me out there and not for the
first time
ragnar's discovery of england and the
monastery at lindisfarne
initiates a century of armed conflict
between the resident anglo-saxons and
the scandinavian raiders covetous of
their fertile shores
in some sense vikings really does begin
at the beginning
lagether is one of the most enduring and
fascinating characters on vikings
the first time we see her on the show
she's hunting eels with her daughter
during the scene the camera pans across
the water
and follows ahead of the spear she's
using to kill the creatures
like many characters on vikings lagatha
is inspired by a possibly
real possibly legendary woman in those
ancient sagas that inspired her
character
spears are a recurring motif in
lagatha's case her story is told in a
13th century history of denmark called
gesta denorum written by the danish
historian saxogramaticus gramaticus
mostly writes about her in the context
of her husband ragnar lothbrok
he indicates that she was ragnar's first
wife and that in order to win lagatha's
love ragnar had to spear a bear to death
and strangle a hound that the fierce
woman kept to protect her
i went to confess my love to her but i
was set upon by a bear
and an enormous hound who guarded her
hung
in another charming chapter from her
life lagatha is said to have killed a
separate powerful husband with a
spearhead she had concealed in her
clothing
with him out of the way lagatha took on
his titles and rolled the land he
controlled that first
image of lagatha's spearing eels is a
nice easter egg for anyone familiar with
the popular symbolism
of the shield maiden's mythology
speaking of ragnar and lagatha's bear
stabbing hound strangling courtship
ragnar tells a familiar story to his son
biern in the first episode
bien seems mildly amused by the story at
the time but it's possible that it
struck a deep accord with him later in
life
when he kills a bear himself in the
season 4 episode
mercy a grown-up bierne goes into the
wilderness alone
to spend the winter fending for himself
in order to prove to ragnar that he has
the strength to be a leader
while decamped at a remote cabin bjorn
encounters a ferocious bear that has
escaped an animal trappy set
after tracking it down he does battle
with the animal emerging victorious if a
bit slashed up
bien never explicitly ruminates on the
symbolism of killing the bear
but based on the stoic gravity of how
the event is portrayed on the show
it's clear that it has meaning to him
beyond the fact that it was a brush with
death
like his father before him bierno has a
major life event associated with killing
a bear
to tie all that up in an even neater bow
in many scandinavian languages bierne is
a word for bear
one of the most complex relationships on
vikings is the one between ragnar and
his brother rolo we were introduced to
rolo in the first episode and although
he has all the skepticism of an older
brother
he encourages ragnar cezaya to set out
on his own to explore the west
later on the show rollo's betrayal of
ragnar will place the brothers on
opposing sides in a series of armed
conflicts careful viewers will have seen
this twist coming right from the start
this dynamic is teased toward the end of
the first episode the two budding
warlords are discussing ragnar's plan to
sail west
when rolo lays out the condition and the
witch will join his brother
i won't go under your command
i won't go when this will all equal
ragnar gives row though assurance that
they are and his statement ends up being
fairly accurate
unfortunately the brothers only find
true equality as rivals
another statement made in the first
episode that has a ring of truth comes
courtesy of floki
ragnar takes beyond to meet the
eccentric shipbuilder who was working on
a boat strong enough to carry ragnar
across the open ocean
to the lands he's heard about in the
west when floki is introduced to
ragnar's son
he gazes into the young man's face and
tells him he has his father's eyes
then adds a less an optimistic
clarification it means he will be like
you
and therefore he will want to do better
than you and you will hate him for it
although bjorn works with ragnar and
supports his father's endeavors for most
of their lives together
there is a crucial moment wherein he
decides to forge his own path
in the fourth season ragnar invites
bjorn and the men who are loyal to him
to travel back to england
the location of many of his most famous
conquests bjorn declines
choosing instead to sail south to
explore the mediterranean this ends up
being the last time they see each other
ragnar goes back to england where he's
captured and killed by king ayla
meanwhile bjern sails to the
mediterranean and beyond where he
establishes political and trading
connections
expanding the footprint of the vikings
far beyond what ragnar was able to
accomplish
in his own lifetime whether or not
ragnar came to hate his son for his
ambitions it's clear that bjorn did
indeed endeavor to do better than his
father
it's just one of the many small ways
that the first episode of vikings clued
the viewers into where the show would
take its story
and characters check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one